[Música]
boa tarde pessoal muito alto
eu resolvi deixa a medicina para fazer
física 2010 a medicina vai perder um
grande mesmo
eu fiquei achando que não já pensou um
médico que vive no mundo da lua no
cosmos
então é uma grande decisão de fazer
medicina
resolvemos então estudar física
cosmologia adaptação do universo e hoje
estou aqui um grande prazer estar com
vocês todos
eu gostaria de fazer um convite a um
convite para uma viagem uma viagem que
vocês nunca fizeram uma viagem virtual
uma viagem ao universo
nós vamos hoje para lugares mais
distantes e talvez um destino lugar mais
distante que seja possível imaginar
nossa primeira estação da saída vai ser
a nossa terra nosso lar
a nossa sofrida terra nosso planeta
passando depois pelo sistema solar
e quando eu vi pela primeira vez esse
planeta saturno e seus anéis e fiquei
tão encantada uma maravilha uma obra de
arte sem precedentes arte cósmica
fantástica
saímos do sistema solar a terra ali no
meio junto do sol
vamos pra nossa galáxia
essa maravilha que tem 400 bilhões de
estrelas é o nosso lugar no cosmos
nós estamos há anos um pouquinho
afastado da do centro da galáxia
talvez aqui mais ou menos nesse ponto e
no centro exatamente dessa galáxia tem
algo que os cientistas descobriram
recentemente muito estranho
um buraco negro buraco negro é um
monstro cósmico que engole tudo o que
passa na sua exigência inclusive à luz e
por isso tem esse nome buraco negro a
gente não pode ver porque a luz que ele
que nós iria conseguir refletir para nós
completamente escuro em instalar o
centro da nossa via láctea e nossa
física hoje consegue explicar porque
pode haver uma alguma coisa tão estranho
como essa no nosso universo
a nossa galáxia ela está nesse slide
naquele pontinho à lei
a via láctea e isto que está em torno
dela é uma aglomeração uma planeado de
outras galáxias próximo a mais próxima
de todas as galáxias nossa vizinha em
andrômeda esta daqui galaxy é muito
bonita parecida com a nossa e nas
vizinhanças dessas duas nós temos várias
outras galáxias é o nosso aglomerado o
universo tem bilhões de aglomerados
nossa viagem apenas começou
a gente vai um pouquinho mais para
frente e vamos muito pela frente muito
longe e essa é a fotografia na região
mais distante que existe no universo o
universo visível a história dessa forma
é muito interessante
os astrônomos um dia resolveram focar
uma área do cosmo completamente escura e
negra e não havia nada nessa aí
resolveram então apontar o telescópio
hubble
essa galáxia para essa região que não
tinha nada aparentemente esperar durante
11 dias à luz se fotografar ela chega e
álcool mexer quando finalmente for olhar
o resultado encontrar essa fotografia
então é o que existe mais longínquo
nosso nível é bom vamos fazer uma viagem
tridimensional
aqui nessa essa fotografia vamos entrar
dentro
isso foi sempre foi possível graças à
nossa altíssima tecnologia
esse filme foi feito pela nasa usando o
telescópio hubble
aqui está a fotografia inicial nós vamos
entrar três dimensões dentro dessa
fotografia
estamos indo cada vez mais pros limites
do universo mais longe mais afastado
nós estamos passando por várias galáxias
cada pontinho de si é uma galáxia
estamos indo às fronteiras do nosso
nosso universo nosso cosmo nova
velocidade estupenda esse cosmo que está
também em expansão com expansão que é
algo muito difícil de explicar por que a
gente pergunta como é que o universo
pode expandir como é que o espaço pode
se planejar
a resposta é muito simples o universo se
expande porque todas as galáxias do
universo estão se afastando umas das
outras
todas elas como fazer uma representação
deste essa idéia é fazer um modelo
rápido a gente ver como é que seria isso
o modelo que eu vou apresentar para
vocês aqui nós temos aí uma espécie de
um balãozinho que está inflando o
primeiro balão ele representaria o
universo certo instante e ali estão as
galáxias
à medida que o tempo vai passando esse
balão vai crescendo e as galáxias que
seriam esses desvios esses insetos
dentro começam a se afastar uma das
outras
é isso que significa mais ou menos à
idéia de que o universo está se
expandindo
[Música]
mas aqui a gente sim fica indagando se
realmente existe essa expansão se o
universo está expandindo
então se nós voltarmos no tempo se
formos por passado
nós vamos ter em vez da expansão a
contração universo está contraindo e
começamos a fazer uma viagem no tempo
passado no universo vai cada vez mais
contraindo contraindo hora vai chegar um
instante um tempo finito esse tempo é da
ordem de r 13 bilhões de anos mais ou
menos nesse tempo então o universo
torna-se um ponto quando o universo
torna-se um ponto
desaparece completamente todo o tudo que
a gente entende como o seu espaço como
sendo tempo a matéria toda concentrada
num ponto
a temperatura se é infinita a densidade
de massa de matéria e infinita também
então temos que os matemáticos físicos
do chamado de uma singularidade ou me
bem mas a gente pensar como é que o
espaço pode desaparecer é que o espaço
pode virar um ponto como é que o tempo
pode deixar de existir
a gente pergunta óbvia hora o que havia
antes do tempo começar a existir essas
perguntas todas as perguntas muito
é difícil a gente responder
existem várias explicações possíveis e
nós vamos tentar ver mais adiante um
pouquinho como é que a gente poderia
abordar esse problema essa questão nos
anos 60 em 1960 e 1970
stephen hawking quando era aluno em oxi
uma palestra do professor roger tem
bronze
e nessa palestra ele ficou muito
intrigado com a a as idéias que o
pessoal estava apresentando a ele e
juntos mas para trabalhar e
desenvolveram do contexto uma teoria a
teoria latim terra geral o teorema este
teorema era fez tal sou um no meio
científico causou uma grande teve grande
repercussão extrema dia seguinte se a
teoria da relatividade geral viaja esta
estiver correta
então essa singularidade assim esse
momento inicial do universo é inevitável
não há escapatória
nós tivemos então o início do tempo do
espaço onde toda a matéria estava
concentrada e essa fase inicial do
universo foi justamente a fase em que
ocorreram a formação os primeiros átomos
nos átomos de hidrogênio o ato de l de
leite os elementos leves da química
foram formados justamente nessa fase
nível
já os elementos pesados em toda a
história muito bonita que foi formado no
interior das estrelas os elementos que
formam a vida foi formado lã dentro das
estrelas nas explosões de estrelas
supernovas foi espalhado por todo o
universo então nós nosso corpo os atos
elementos do nosso corpo e as estrelas
em que é muito bonito isso pois bem
mas essa questão de ter existido um
momento inicial sem perturbou muito a
comunidade dos físicos como é que
poderia acontecer isso é bom pra
explicar a dinâmica do universo seja
esse movimento do universo a expansão
tudo isso
a teoria que tem que ser usada é a
teoria da relatividade geral de einstein
que foi formulado em 1915
então é essa teoria
ela na verdade ela é considerada pelos
físicos como talvez a mais bela teoria
que nós temos porque ela conseguiu um
feito notável que foi ligar a geometria
explicar a força de gravitação há a
teoria da gravitação que nós acreditam
na teoria de newton
por exemplo nós temos na escola pois bem
essa força gravitacional ela deixa de
ser uma força e passa a ser uma
geometria é uma geometria curva então
com essa idéia de que a força da
gravitação geometria por exemplo é muito
interessante a gente olhar o que é
exatamente porque que um planeta entrou
em órbita em torno do twitter por
exemplo o que a terra está em órbita em
torno do sol
será que nós aprendemos primeiro na
escola é porque há porque existe uma
força gravitacional que está o tempo
todo atraindo a terra para o sol
a teoria da relatividade geral oferece
uma outra ideia isso não é verdade é
exatamente assim o sol cria de forma ao
espaço um espaço tempo e até então segue
uma linha é a linha mais simples
possível nessa geometria essa linha
acaba sendo uma órbita assim com a gente
tá vendo aqui então essa idéia muito
elegante da teoria da relatividade geral
reduzir a gravitação a física a uns a
uma geometria
pois bem então a outro lado a gente sabe
que pra explicar o universo a gente tem
que ver como é que as galáxias como é
que os corpos celestes interagem entre
si como é que um nota a presença do
outro e à gravitação atraente a força
que realmente domina o universo hora mas
a gravitação e geometria então é a
geometria que está por trás de tudo isso
nessa geometria a gente explicar
primeiro porque o universo expandindo
expandindo tão rápido
era domingo segundo
como é que foi essa fase inicial muito
quente em que os elementos químicos
foram formados pela primeira vez ainda
mais
e como fica essa questão do primeiro
início do estágio inicial da
singularidade bem bom aqui nós temos uma
representação gráfica não a
representação pictórica e como seria
essa história do universo
esse pontinho laranja que está aqui
significaria digamos esse big ben o
início de tudo
já essa fase vermelha corresponde
justamente a momento em que a
temperatura do universo extremamente
alto e que começam a ser formados os
primeiros elementos químicos
depois o universo continua em sua
expansão e essa forma de ensino
representa justamente essa expansão a
gente nota que a imediatamente após o
big ben
uma expansão notável justamente nessa
linha aqui muito rápida e essa é essa
expansão muito rápida chamada de
inflação
depois o universo se expande - e nós
acabamos ficando nessa fase aqui mais ou
menos é onde nós estamos e depois tem
essa expansão extremamente acelerada
rápida que é justamente a expansão será
que nós observamos hoje como explicar
isso
como explicar essa fase inicial por
exemplo como explicar se acelera essa
expansão acelerada
existem vários modelos
a física é uma ciência que em que a as
teorias nunca são definitivas não é
verdade definitiva na física existem
penas verdades provisórias
ela vale enquanto não for contestada por
alguma observação por 1 a 1
a contestação experimental observacional
então os físicos comum como os
cientistas isso é muito estranho são
pessoas muito estranho é você deve ter
saber disso uma vez me lembro quando me
formei em física e ficava um pouco
constrangido porque alguém perguntava
até que você faz isso física e fez a
interessante você não parece maluco você
não parece não parece muito com a gente
tem algum estranho então os estranhos
porque porque toda vez que um físico uma
comunidade lança um novo modelo do
universo ou da física ele se com ficam
logo doidos prá com ele pra conseguir
mostrar que existe algum defeito aquela
teoria então e é por isso que a fifa
avança porque o seu modelo errado a
gente tem que tratar o outro modelo
consertar o modelo e assim nós vamos
adiante
então existem vários modelos para as
teorias para explicar o universo para
explicar por exemplo a fase inicial a
expansão acelerada é verdade que existem
aqueles que são mais aceitos pela
comunidade por exemplo existe o uma hora
vai entrar um pouco no jargão técnico na
tecla usar um termo campo escalar
inflation esse influxo o nome técnicos
físicos significa que ele é um campo que
faz com que esse universo spam dar muito
rapidamente e faz com que haja a
expansão inicial da fase inicial do
universo seja causada por ele
não sabemos de onde vem esse infrator
nós não sabemos esse campo escalar de
onde vêm os filhos não sabe o que é bom
é uma energia escura mas que a energia
escura é essa que nós não vemos
exatamente escura porque nós não vemos
mais um campus kalla eles vão campo
escalar mas de onde vem esse campus
calar essas indagações todas ainda são
hoje delegações estão em aberto ninguém
sabe ainda responder e existem vários
deles e nós então vamos entrar um
pouquinho no nosso trabalho de pesquisa
que nós desenvolvemos nosso grupo aqui
na universidade
nós fomos buscar
inspiração nas idéias de einstein a
gente tem é quem pensava que a geometria
era capoeira explicar ia tudo isso nós
vamos buscar um campo escalar de uma
geometria encontramos descobrimos que
herman vaiou matemático famoso do século
20 em pinhas descoberto e inventado uma
geometria escalar nós que estudamos
submeter a escalar e descobrimos que
poderiam explicar talvez essa fase
inicial
essa inflação inicial do universo
poderia explicar essa expansão acelerada
usando hoje me teria que é algo muito
mais natural e surgimento ea gerente do
espaço tempo e manter ligado à
gravitação
não precisamos buscar uma energia escura
para explicar esse fato e talvez achem
que fez gostar dessa ideia porque não
muito bem então essa pergunta não seria
o campus calar e vaiou essa geometria
essa energia procurada é essa então é a
nossa proposta e nós estamos avançando
termos avançado bastante nisso
claro que existe um outro outra questão
por exemplo que é a da regularidade
aí essa esse início do tempo seria
causado pelo campo escalar seria causado
pela geometria
nós acreditamos que sim nós estamos
envolvendo no momento um esforço muito
interessante estamos conseguindo bons
resultados para mostrar que de fato esse
campus carla estaria também na origem do
do nosso universo
mas isso é um efeito que entra no
terreno da física quântica não
propriamente a cosmologia da cosmologia
quântica um pouco mais vai ter uma
palestra que vai falar um pouquinho e
física quântica pra vocês eu fico por
aqui muito obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]